There's many red flags that can come
up during the interview process but
I think there isn't a magic formula.
I think it really comes with
experience of the founders.
The one thing I will say is that
it's okay to take risks and hire
individuals that you are uncertain of
but make sure to fire quickly, as well.
Because if it doesn't work,
it's not just bad for the business,
it's actually bad for
the employee that you hired, as well.
If there are red flags, clearly,
you don't want to hire.
But if you are unsure and there's
sparks that you see in the employee,
you might consider giving them a chance.
Especially, if you feel like they can
really push your startup forward.
One thing that I have seen entrepreneurs
do well is have the employee
tell the story of the startup
that they're applying to.
What is it about
the startup that they like?
What are the things they look for in
the next opportunity that they're doing?
Usually red flags come up when they
don't really understand the business or
don't really identify or have different
motivations to join the startup
then what the founders
expect them to have.
For example, they're looking for
a job that's close to their home.
Perhaps but
usually that leads to misalignments
later on and of expectations later on.